Hello and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host David Flanagan,
also known across the Internet as Rawkode.
Today is another episode of Rawkode live where
we take a look at open source software
within the cloud native DevOps cloud world
and try to help you solve some challenges
with interest in software. Today is no exception.
We're tackling the wonderful world of secrets and
secret operations and secrets management.
And today, we're taking a look at a
project called Infisical,
And I'm joined by Vlad from the Infisical
team to walk us through it. Hey, Vlad.
How are you?
Hey.
Doing great. How are you? Yeah. Not too
bad. This is always the highlight of my
day, but I get to take a look
at some awesome open source software. So before
we talk about Infisical, could you please take
a moment to introduce yourself and tell everyone
about you?
Yeah. Yeah. Of course. My name is Vlad.
Thanks so much for having me. My name
is Vlad. I'm one of the cofounders of
Infisical,
one of the first maintainers
as well of the open source project.
And, yep, previously,
I worked at,
which is now one of the largest neobanks
in Europe. I also worked at Figma.
I I think a lot of developers probably
know Figma. It's a very popular design tool.
And yeah. And and now I'm building in
physical. I I guess
I'll answer more questions about it. Yeah. Yeah.
We can get into that definitely.
Yeah. That's a good lineage you've got. At
Figma, I think you're right. Everybody's heard of
it.
Yeah. What's interesting is
I I like WebAssembly a lot, and I
always go into conferences and talk about it.
And I'm like, who's used WebAssembly?
They always nobody ever puts their hands up.
And I'm like, well, you're just using it.
You don't know. Like, Infisq is always the
example. Like, if it's like their their platform
is made possible, I believe, through a lot
of WebAssembly. Anyway, I digress. It is. And
and Figma was one of the first users
and and, like, proponents of it ever. So
yeah.
Amazing what you can do with web technologies.
So Yeah. Let's take a look at your
current let's talk about your your new project
and physicall.
First,
you're a brave person tackling secrets. Right? I
mean, that to me is a scary thing.
I I would never, in my right mind,
think I'm gonna sit down and make the
world secure by creating
a secrets management platform. So maybe you could
give us a bit of history of why
you decided to tackle this problem. It is
well well, first of all, yes. It's a
it's a scary problem, but, also, it is
one of the biggest problems that developers and
companies and different engineering organizations
and teams face.
And and and it's one of those problems
that they're they kinda you know, like, first
of all, there is no perfect solution for
it yet.
And
because all the solutions that are available have
certain kind of limitations.
And
developers are also not really willing to build
a solution in house just because of high
how high
the stakes are
for it. And and which is why we
decided to build Infisical,
which is, you know, a single platform,
source
that you're able to use for managing your
application
and infrastructure credentials
across, well, all of your infrastructure, across your
engineering teams,
with your teammates,
and and so on.
Awesome.
This is a space, you know, as I
go back five years and was predominantly either
crazy enterprise
call us pricing. Right? You know, tools. I
think CyberArk was probably one of the bigger
ones.
Or or Vault, which is open source, but
is notoriously
difficult to operate. And trust me, I I
have tried many times and I'm sure you
maybe have in the past as well.
It's it's very difficult. And Infisical seems to
come out of that from a different point
of view. It's it's not scary. It doesn't
seem
challenging to operate. I guess that's something that
you set out from the start to be
like, let's make this different. Is that a
fair assumption?
It it it is. And and how we
view so something that I'll also say is
how we view Infisical as we try to
center it around the trend of security shift
left.
And this is ultimately a trend where, you
you know, in the early days, predominantly security
was the responsibility of a single team within
the organization,
which is basically the security team.
But right now, what's happening is that you
see companies like Mercedes
or
Uber
or AstraZeneca,
they they are using secret managers and, you
know, like, some of those companies that you
mentioned, and yet their their secrets are still
leaked.
So they're kinda, like, not
protected against those kind of
disasters.
And and, obviously, for them, it's very high
stakes. For AstraZeneca,
they have lots of medical data and and
and so on.
And so what's happening is that developers
are kinda, like, kept outside the loop, and
they don't have the right tools to actually
act responsibly and and code securely and follow
these secure practices.
And so this is what we provide within
Infisical. And and our goal
and kinda, like, our
thinking about it is that you can build
the most secure tool ever,
could be Vault. But if it's so hard
to operate,
developers are just not going to use it,
and they're gonna find ways around it.
So, ultimately,
it's not reaching its goal.
And and this is what we want to
solve within Infisical. We want to provide a
very simple solution,
and we want to provide all these kinda,
like, leftmost tools for developers
to operate secrets. You know, whether it's CLI
or secret scanning products that we provide or
some other secret sharing features,
you should be able to do it within
physical in just one platform.
Yeah. I resonate with what you just said
there a lot. You know, I'm in the
Kubernetes space. I've been there for a while
and, you know, we
vault was never part of anyone's Kubernetes cluster.
And maybe now, but it wasn't for the
last seven years. And instead, we came up
with these workaround solutions to the point we
have tools like SOPS from Mozilla,
where we actually just encrypt everything in the
story and get. And then key management becomes
a challenge after that, and our secrets become
very static. Right? We can't work with them
with SDKs. Like, one of the coolest features,
but in physical, it's okay to use. We
can do really cool things with our our
secret properties.
Yeah. Throwing things that get encrypted. I never
resonated with me. I hated it. And I
think that's just because vault was notoriously difficult
and people didn't wanna take that that burden
on.
So
yeah. I'm hoping people will be excited with
what they're gonna see about Infisical.
But before we jump into the demo, I
think you tell us about the name. Where
did that come from?
Well,
the name actually doesn't doesn't mean much. What
what it means is it means kinda like
infinite and physical. So it's in physical
or or beyond physical.
You know, we are operating a lot of
these credentials
and and everything.
And yeah.
But but that's kinda it's kinda like a
combination of engineering and DevOps and and these
kinds of
things. Yeah. It it was it was also
I must say, was it was available in
a .com domain, and we wanted the .com
domain.
Always a big part of starting a company.
Right? Is what could all.org do you get?
Right. Yeah. Your your infinity logo works with
the name, and, of course, the DevOps cycle
loop is also that kind of infinity thing.
So I guess there's a lot. If you
wanna make up a really compelling story, it's
definitely waiting there for you.
Yeah.
Alright. Shall we get hands on and show
people how they can get started and what
Infisical is? You happy for that? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Perfect. Let me just clear,
you know, a kinda like a sample
and physical project.
Mhmm.
Yeah. Are you able to see my screen?
It's a it's a very, indeed. Yeah. It's
live. Go
Perfect. So I I created a, you know,
a Rawkode organization
here, and right now, we're in the project
call server
just for folks to understand.
And so, ultimately, when you are in the
Infisical project,
the first
difference that you see from, you know, traditional
secret management solutions
is that we have this concept
of environments.
So in this case, you see that in
this project, we have development staging
and, you know, three different production environments, such
as prod Asia, prod US, and prod EU.
And these are highly customizable.
You know, we see a lot of engineering
teams have, for example, like a preprode environments
or multiple staging environments or some some teams
have different development environments for features they are
developing
and so on.
So, yeah, this environment concept is is very
common across, you know, like, how engineering teams
organize their secrets and their applications.
And and this screen gives you a bird's
eye view of everything that's happening. You can
immediately know if a secret is missing in
a particular environment
or if if if the secret is there,
but the value is not specified yet.
You can immediately see it on the screen.
Yeah.
What what are the red squares at the
top for Asia and EU?
These are just telling you, you know, you're
missing two secrets compared to other environments. Alright.
So if you're you you see we're missing
email, SMTP. We're missing Stripe publishable key. So
then it just tells you, hey. Like, be
careful. There is, like, two secrets missing.
Alright. Nice. Yep. Because, ultimately, like, why why
this view exists is because we've seen times
and times, you know, when developers are deploying
something and then they accidentally
forgot to specify
a certain environment variable or secrets or configuration.
And then they're, you know, they're trying to
figure out why their deployments don't work, and
and this feature makes these things much, much
easier.
Yeah. That's one of the things I've noticed
from exploring Infisical and going through the documentation.
It's not you don't you're not just encouraging
people just to put the secret material in
it. You're like, just get rid of your
ENV file. Just put everything into Infisical, and
then you have this level of visibility of
what's missing and what's not and so forth.
And I I like that approach. Yes.
It it it could be anything. So now
if we go into any particular environment,
so we can go so what you see
here is, you know, a set of key
value pairs,
but the value itself can be anything. It
could be a multiline secret, for example, like
a JSON file. It could be an SSH
certificate.
And in in physical, kinda, like, automatically parse
it for you in the right format,
But it could also be a configuration.
It it it yeah. It's really anything that
you might that differentiates your environment,
yeah, across different environments.
Next.
Yeah.
And so now we are you can see
we're in the development environment.
And here, it's kinda like a deeper view
into any particular environment.
There is a lot of features
that are
embedded into it. So for example, if you
take the DB URL,
you can see that the value is a
MongoDB access token.
And the cool thing about it is that
it's actually able to reference other secrets. So
in this case, you can see that we
are referencing database password and database username.
So every time we update database password and
database username,
it will actually be propagated
to,
you know, all the other mentions of this
particular sequence. And and right now, you know,
we are querying it from this particular environment.
We could also
query it from
reference it from other environments. So in this
case, we're you're doing it from staging.
And, yeah, it it it it's really up
to you on how you want to set
it up. Yeah.
I like that.
Yeah. And and this feature, you know, a
lot of engineers using us, they like it
a lot because, ultimately, you know, it automates
a lot of things. It allows them to
just update the secret once,
and the values will be propagated everywhere it's
being used.
So it becomes very convenient.
Yeah. And and there's lots of other things.
So for example, you can add tags
to your
secrets. If you have hundreds or we have
some teams have thousands or tens of thousands
of secrets,
then this becomes very convenient because they can
just filter or search for those later on.
You can also add comments
to your secrets.
So, you know, if you're onboarding new people
to your team or you just want to
remember how to generate a certain encryption key,
then you can just specify it here. You
can think of it as metadata fields,
and you will always kinda, like, have it
nearby.
Cool.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And
let's see. What else? Another thing that that
people like a lot is this feature called
overwrites.
So
by default,
all these
all these secrets
are shared
across
users or machines that have access to a
particular environment.
But with the override feature,
for example, let's say I'm a developer and
and I'm working on a new feature. There
is a certain for example, I update my
SendGrid ID
to another value. Now I can just click
this button, and it's gonna override it with
my personal value without affecting the workflows for
the rest of the team.
And so this is useful for either, you
know, like local development when you constantly have
to update these values
to try out new things, or this is
also useful for highly sensitive things like database
password and database username. They will likely be
unique for every engineer,
So then you can just override them with
their personal values.
I guess, yeah, if you're, like, a platform
team, you could provide the key with an
empty value, and then everyone has to go
in and provide their override.
Yeah. Exactly. So, like, what we see people
do is either provide it with an empty
value or, for example, in this case, you
see the value is just username, and then,
you know, I have to go ahead and
change it with Vlad. There is also a
comment that says override.
So you you like, people kinda know that
they have to override it.
Yeah. Flick.
Yeah.
And
yeah. Let's see. Everything is obviously version controlled,
so you're able to see how the secret
value has been changing over time.
And this also ties into the point of
time recovery functionality.
So you can every time you make a
change with your secrets in any particular environment,
you can go always go back in time
and just roll back with a single button.
And, yeah, here you can, you know, inspect
the changes. And this is very useful if
you make an error or you just want
to see
what has happened in this particular snapshot for
debugging purposes, for example.
Okay. Cool. I guess it also gives you
visibility into, like, if someone on the team,
their machine was compromised and someone updated
values,
then you would have full visibility into how
to handle that.
Yeah. So this one is actually even more
than that. You would you should look into
audit logs
because Infisical automatically,
you know, logs all of these different events.
And, you know, it you can filter it
by source. You know? So, like, are you
is it happening through the SDKs or web
or CLI,
whatever it is.
And here it's asked, you know, like, who
is the actor, whether it's user or machine,
which user, for example, or which machine,
what's the source.
For example, right now, we're looking at in
web, and this is my I p v
six address.
And here, like, some metadata fields that are
specific to every event.
So, yes, here, you would be able to
see, you know, like, everything
that that could be happening.
Oh, so if someone's machine was compromised, you
could literally come into here, filter by the
user, and get every read from a certain
point of time, and then you know to
have to go and re rotate all of
those credentials.
Yes. Exactly. So you're you're able to rotate
either manually or we have automatic rotation.
Yeah.
Very cool. So you're able you're able to
see it all here. You you're also able
to integrate it with your logging solution.
If you're using, like, a SIEM or something,
then,
yes, this would be very helpful for for
these kind of, like, compliance use cases.
Yeah.
Yeah. Let's see. So while
we're still at it, so something that I'll
also say is by default,
the structure of Secrets and Infisical is very
flat, and this is because,
you know, when we see engineers
start using Infisical,
this is kinda like what they want
because they don't need all this complexity
that traditionally been with, like, different path and
and so on in secret management.
But sometimes, you know, when teams
become larger and and their projects and and
products become larger,
then there starts to they start to have
the need for for folders. And this is
basically functionality
of organizing secrets in the in the particular
directories.
You can nest these folders infinitely.
So, really, you are able to create the
structure
that works for your use case. It's very,
very highly customizable.
Is there, from your experience, a preferred approach
to how to use folders or go flat?
Do you see something that works better, or
is it purely down to the team and
what they're doing?
It's really down to the team.
It it also really depends. For example, some
teams are changing to Infisical from existing secret
managers, so they've already been using something before.
So then they are trying to imitate the
structure
from those secret managers into Infisical.
So yeah. And and then they're very easily
able to do that with folders.
But but, really, you know, like, one thing
that we see is, for example,
split by microservices
or kinda, like, split by functionalities,
for example, like
billing or email or some people also put
kinda, like, more sensitive secrets into a specific
folder, and then they are able to access
control this folder
much easier.
For example, there could be a folder with
encryption keys
and and kinda like very few people on
the team would get access to that.
Okay. So
folders can also be a means of splitting
up the the RBAC across the project.
If if it's flat, everybody has access to
to everything. But if you bring in folders,
you can change the policies across the folders,
if I understood that correctly.
Yeah. Yes. Yes. Definitely. And I I can
also show you how it works in in
a few minutes.
But, yes, the the RBAC access controls, you're
you're able to integrate them
very well with folders.
Alright. Nice.
Yeah.
And
yeah. So, actually, access control is a huge
part, obviously, of Infisical, you know, just because
of the nature of of secret management.
But before we move on to that, I
I wanna show you another feature
that people
are usually very excited about. So here, you
can see that we are in the prod
Asia environment.
And here, we have this green icon
that says
prod US. And and what this means is
actually an important icon.
So what's
happening is that
we actually inside our prod Asia environment, we
are inheriting the secrets from the prod US
environment. So prod US becomes our core production
environment,
and then the rest of the secrets is
actually being overridden. So they are unique for
prod Asia. Some secrets will be equivalent, like
the same across two environments. Some secrets will
be different,
and and this is what you can see
here.
Okay.
Yeah. There are a lot of other use
cases for it. Sometimes it's with some kind
of preview environments or staging environments or pre
prod environments.
Kinda like having the score environment could be
very handsy. So what takes precedence here? The
imports or the secrets
below it?
The the secrets afterwards. Right. Right. You you
can kinda see here, you know, if if
it's present in the dashboard, it means that
the secret is being overridden
by specific Asian secrets.
Very cool. Yeah. I like that. I don't
think I really fully comprehended how that works,
but I have used the imports. I have
microservices,
and I realized that I was copying the
same three tokens all the time in all
of them. And then I end up just
creating a folder at the top and then
import that into each microservice. And it worked
really well. But yeah.
Yeah. The this is what people do as
well. Because so for example, you know, some
people might have a folder
with, for example,
email,
like SendGrid related secrets,
And then they need to import the same
folder into all of their environments. So they
then they're able to take this folder from,
let's say, the core environment. They have it
in physical and import it everywhere everywhere else.
So then, you know, if they need to
update the secret, they only update it once
and it gets propagated everywhere.
Alright. Nice. I like that.
Yeah.
Let's see. So we can probably move on
to the access controls.
So in in Infisical, how you can think
about it is we have the concept of
identities,
and these identities could either be humans or
machines.
So for for example, humans, you know, it's
any developer, any DevOps engineer
who has access to the Infisical dashboards
or
also, you know, API or CLI or all
the other formats
that we provide for accessing secrets.
But identities could also be machines. And so
machine identities are useful for, for example, managing
CICD pipelines or your production environments
or, you know, something more automated.
So you you basically, how you can think
of it is is people are kinda like
more manual workflows,
and machines are much more automated workflows.
But the nice part about it is that
they're kinda equivalent,
and both of them have the role
that can be assigned to it.
And then this role gives them the corresponding
set of permissions for accessing specific environments
and and so on.
Some roles are available by default,
but you're actually able to create any role,
the any custom role that you want. And
you're able to specify, for example, in the
prod Asia environment for these specific secrets,
people are only able to maybe create new
secrets, but they can't view or modify or
delete the existing ones.
So,
yeah, they very you know, again, very, very
highly customizable roles.
You can do
you can manage roles or project members or
environments
or service tokens with them
and, yeah, make sure that people have the
right set of permissions or machines.
Nice.
Yeah.
I I I know you were also like,
you I think you had some kinda, like,
suggestions about more, like, attribute based access controls,
if I remember correctly.
Yeah. That comes back to kind of my
mono repository use case where Yeah. You know,
I I think for my situation and I
don't know how niche that is versus what
you see from all your actual customers and
such. But,
you know, I think there's rules to access
secrets, which I mean, you've got rules. Right?
But like say,
a DevOps person, they're always gonna need access
to secrets tagged with cloud or infra or
whatever. And I just figured that approach scales
better for a mono repository
where I can't I don't wanna have to
be configured loads of paths all the time.
Yeah.
It it could work. So we you know,
we've been thinking about it a lot,
and and we are actually right now soon
we will be releasing the revamp
to access controls.
And so and and, you know, it's access
controls as well as all the other adjacent
features to it.
And maybe I can talk about two of
them in a bit.
But, yes, I I think there is definitely
a lot of room for this kinda, like,
tag based or attribute based
access controls. There is also a lot of
rules that you can
add on top of that. For example, you
know, if a user is accessing secrets
from a particular IP address, then they get
a role x.
But if they're accessing it from a different
IP address or from a different network, then
they get a role y.
So these kind of, like,
changing roles is also a very, very interesting
concept.
Yeah. I guess you you've you've got people
using this d n d. I'm sure you
use it yourselves, d n d. Like, it's
it's like that video. I don't know if
you ever seen it. It went viral on
Twitter maybe last year. And it's like the
the designer watching someone play with their product
and it's like the box with the star
hole and the circle hole and the square
hole and they put all the shapes in
the one hole and they're like Yeah. With
that. It's like,
you know, when you have an open source
project, the people are always gonna think we
are the wonderful ways to use it. So
it's just nice and refreshing when
people take on board ideas and and talk
about them. So, yeah, I'm excited to see
what he's come up with.
No. It it it it's gonna be very
cool. So so one thing that we also
already have is something called secret approvals. I
I don't know if you
if you had a look into that before.
But, basically, how it works is
so you see, we are right now in
the Prod US environment. And in the Prod
US environment, there is this lock icon, and
it says that it's protected by policy,
prod US.
So now if, you know, as an engineer,
if I want to update secrets in this
particular environment,
it actually
one process might change. Instead, it will work
similar to how you commit or raise a
PR in Git.
You know? So before merging your code to
main, it has to be approved by one
or multiple other people on your team.
And we have the similar concept with secrets.
You know? Before you merge your changes into
the production environments, it has to be approved
by one of the admins on the team
that you prespecify or maybe multiple admins.
And here, you see you someone submit a
request, then I'm able to approve or reject
it
depending on, you know, if if it makes
sense or not. And
you these policies, you know, they can be
specified
very freely. You can specify who is able
to make changes for or approve changes for
every particular environment and how many approvals you
need
and so on. And and, actually, how this
feature started is
one of our
customers,
she used to be a
head of infrastructure in in a very large
company, and they had this
error twice where they updated secrets
and
like, a one of the production environments.
And they they made a mistake accidentally because
there wasn't a second person to kinda, like,
look over the change, and then the production
went down twice. So first of all, like,
this approval functionality is good for compliance and
making sure that nothing goes into production
that's unwanted,
but, also, it just gives you another set
of eyes
to make sure that everything is stable.
Yeah. I like that that pull request format
for making changes. That's very cool. I I
I'd
seen the thing in the menu bar. I'd
never clicked on it because I'm a team
of one. So I just I was like,
I don't know what that is. And but,
yeah, I can see how that's really gonna
be beneficial for larger teams that are that
are working. Yeah. And and and you know
what? Actually, I feel like we hear this
a lot,
and I think we're gonna be unifying this
in the larger, you know, access control tab,
which is gonna be, like, universal, all the
things around access controls
and in physical
that that that you might need. And there
is another thing, another feature that will be
coming out very soon
here,
and it will probably be called temporary access.
And how it works is, you know, sometimes
imagine you have your deployments on Tuesday,
and there is a team of engineers who
needs to have access
to the preprode environments for these specific hours
on this specific day.
So what you're able to do within Infisical
is
you're able to set up a schedule or
as an admin, you can just kinda, like,
issue this temporary access.
And then on this specific time for a
specific number of period of time,
the these specific engineers will get access to
this environment.
And after the access expires,
you can specify for secrets to be automatically
rotated.
So
That's cool.
Yeah. So this kinda, like, temporary access is
is something that we see a lot of
teams want,
you know, from the smallest teams
kinda like startups to very large
corporations as well.
So yeah.
I can imagine a scenario where
there's some sort of incident and data you
know, developers who don't normally access production database,
whether it might be PII or whatever, can
elevate their permissions. And then as soon as
they're finished with that incident, it all gets
rotated to behind the scenes, and then they
lose their access.
That's Yeah. Powerful.
Powerful.
Be because there are those kinda, like, high
stakes situation
where, you know, if if developers don't have
access to that, then they kinda, like, can't
do much.
But Although, they'll ways around
it, and then they'll break the entire process.
Right? You have to find a way that
is allows people to do their job, but
in a way that does keep security first
and,
you know, front and center. Right? And and
I think that's really important.
Yeah. Exactly. And
and and this is one of those features
around security shift left
that I've been talking about because traditionally, what's
happening is that, you know, in traditional secret
managers,
if if something like this happens, then the
the engineer on the or, like, the team
that's responsible for secret management,
they somehow try to find a way to
give particular secrets access to these specific engineers.
But then what's happening is that they somehow
get a hold of those secrets, then they
store them potentially in unwanted places like Slack
or or Notes or whatever it is.
And, you know, it it's much more better
it's much, much better to store everything in
Infisical and rotate them at the right schedule.
Yeah.
Yeah. Very cool feature.
So I guess Yeah. You've mentioned that there's
there's a few things that's coming up and
you're working on that are going to be
deployed soon.
Maybe you could, like what what does soon
mean for Infisical? Do you just release every
month? Do you release every quarter? Is it
every day? Like
So yeah. Right. Let maybe I can stop
sharing.
Sorry.
It's alright. Everybody's
done that before. It's one of the most
frustrating things about where that button is. So
don't worry about it whatsoever.
I accidentally
decided to hang up. I'm done with this
guy. I'm away. Yeah.
At least the reconnect button was right there,
so I was able to reconnect immediately
when I realized what happened.
But yeah. So so, actually, that's a that's
a really interesting question because previously, we used
to be on on a rolling release schedule.
So we were, you know, basically releasing features,
you know, after testing them out thoroughly
as we go.
Right now, we are actually moving more towards
kinda like a scheduled release schedule.
Think it's going to be around monthly.
Mhmm. And we're gonna have kinda like a
particular day every month
that we are releasing features.
And,
yeah, that that that's how it works. So
for example, with
with the feature around temporary access, I think
we're gonna be releasing it for around two
weeks or so.
And
yeah. So you you the you know, our
team is actually moving very, very quickly.
If you I don't know if you are
keeping up with our development on GitHub and
and so on, but you can see, you
know, like, how many commits and PRs we're
merging.
Yeah.
Is there are you talking about the demo?
Do you want me to throw more questions
there, or do wanna show a few more
things? Yeah.
I I mean,
let's
continue with the demo then.
Let me
yeah.
Can you see it again? Yeah. It's back
up. Yeah. Perfect. So, obviously, the most important
part
about Infisical is is, you know, how you
actually access these secrets
across your
applications.
So
and within Infisical, we provide a lot of
different ways. So first of all, we have
the integrations,
you know, with all the different clouds and
and developer tools,
or let's say not all of them, but
but a large part of them and and
certainly some of the most
popular ones.
And so an example for that could be
Vercel
or, you know, Heroku or actions or CircleCI
or,
you know, any anything else that you see
on this dashboard, and, potentially, there is more
in the documentation.
But how it works is is, for example,
let's take GitHub or Vercel as an example.
You can integrate Infisical with your Infisical projects,
and every time you update a secret in
Infisical, it will actually be propagated
to
these projects. So what happens is that you're
able to create a central source of truth
for
your secrets
and make sure that there's no discrepancies,
like, for for your secrets across all the
different platforms, whether it's GitHub or Vercel or
Subabase or, you know, any other platforms that
you might be using.
And,
yeah, and and and what we see a
lot is we see, for example, a lot
of teams with, you know, like, example, hundred
different Heroku applications,
and then they are able to centralize everything
in Infisical
and, you know, in a in a very
nice looking dashboards with all the different environments
compared to each other.
Yeah. Have you tried creating an integration yet?
I'm not I'm not sure.
I have. It's one of the main selling
points for me of centralizing my secrets. You
know, the fact that I could put everything
into this product, and then I don't have
to worry about copy and paste and and
to get up actions or claim their workers
and so forth. Just being able to pick
that up and then it automatically does the
same.
It it it's such a nice feature, and
it encourages me to have better security posture.
I'm not going for the back door of
saying, well, I'm just gonna store this password
on my desktop because I need to for
the next day, I'm deploying in two weeks
or whatever. Like, I I just have confidence
now that if I put them here, they're
in the right place and they get to
the right place. And that's very cool.
Yeah. No. Exactly. And and this becomes very
handy kinda like the more services you're using
and the more applications you have, the more
of a problem it becomes.
And especially,
you know, like, if you start having a
larger team,
then Infisical's
integrations become very handy because you have a
single source of truth and and
everything stays secure.
Yeah. I've also found that in some cases,
well, the other way, like, instead of trying
to sync things somewhere,
like, the the JavaScript SDK is also so
good that I'm finding in my applications. I'm
actually just trying to fetch the secrets
where they're needed well.
And then all it means I only have
to sync one thing to these different services
and then the apps can fetch whatever they
need beyond that. It does expose a little
bit of risk because my tokens probably have
access to too much for the application that
they need.
But, you know, based on the access control
stuff that you're talking about and things that
are going to come, that will get tidied
up into a course. So
Yeah. And and you can also, for example,
restrict the IP addresses
and
do a lot of different things around
security in this sense. Yeah. I like the
flexibility,
and it just you know, you can tackle
each of these problems in many different ways
within Infisical. It's again, it comes down to
what works best for the team, what they're
trying to do, and that's the approach they
should be taking.
Yeah. Yeah. Sure.
And so so these are kinda like, you
know, the integrations on the cloud and all
the different platform
type of things.
Something that's also
very helpful, and and, you know, it it's
admittedly helpful for a different set of developers,
but it's a lot of different infrastructure integrations.
So starting from managing your secrets in Docker
to Kubernetes to Terraform to Ansible
or, you know, Jenkins pipelines,
it it could really be anything, and it
depends on how the the team.
Oh, sorry. I just realized that you're probably
not able to see my screen No. Anymore.
Right. But I switched to a different tab.
Hold on. Let me maybe
I'm not gonna hang up again. I'm just
gonna stop sharing and change
the tab.
Yeah. Can you see it now?
Yes. We see the Terraform.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Perfect. Yeah. No. What I
what I was just gonna tell you, it's,
for example, with Terraform, you're able to provision
different secrets and other resources. And in physical,
you can, for example, create a physical project
and so on. So all of these automations
are possible.
We have multiple ways to integrate with Kubernetes.
But, ultimately, what they allow you to do
is they allow you to kinda, like, stay
up to date with all the latest secret
versions.
And as soon as you update a secret
and you're in physical instance, it will actually
be automatically propagated to your applications, and your
applications will be redeployed.
So you don't need to think about the
deployment aspect yourself, and and this is
probably, like, one of for teams that are
using Kubernetes, I think this is one of
the most
loved features
often physical.
Yes. Now one of the first things I
install into my Kubernetes clusters is the is
the operator. So
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And,
yeah, and and another kinda, like, tangential
thing feature is Infisical Agent.
And, basically, it works similar to a sidecar,
which is render which is able to render
your secrets
according to a specific template. So you you,
you know, you specify a template here,
and whatever your application is,
it's able to
to get those secrets.
And you don't need to change any code
logic internally in your application.
Oh, I hadn't seen that before, but that's
pretty cool.
Yeah. I guess because it's fairly new. It's
probably, like, a couple months old.
Yeah. But but I guess what I'm trying
to say is that within Infisical and and
ultimately for any secret management solution you're using,
it will only be useful if it's able
to integrate
with,
you know, like, ideally,
all of your all of the tools, infrastructure,
developer tools that you're using.
But, you know, but at least, like, a
very, very large majority of those.
And which is why we take these integrations
very seriously. And whatever the engineering teams out
there could be using, you know, whether it's
Ansible or or diff all the different other
infrastructure
tools, TeamCity, GitHub Actions, GitLab,
you know, and and Jenkins is a very,
very popular one as well,
then they should be able to do that
within Infisical.
And they they should be able to simplify
secret management there. And while simplifying,
they will also make it more secure
because their developers will now be,
you know, more much more likely to use
a simple solution for secret management in this
particular environment.
Yeah. Definitely.
Yeah.
And,
yeah, I mean, there is quite a lot
of things
that are other to Infisical.
So one of the maybe I can stop
sharing at this point. You know, one one
of the things that I
how we view Infisical
is it's a single platform for managing secrets.
And what this could mean is
also
secret scanning functionalities.
So if if you are or are not
familiar with secret scanning,
it's, you know,
a set of tools that prevents your secrets
from being leaked.
And one of the very common examples for
that is hard coding secrets into Git.
So what we do within Infisical is using
our CLI,
we are able to prevent commits
that have hard coded secrets inside them.
So we have an algorithm embedded there. It
runs locally on your machine,
and it's able to identify any hard coded
secrets
and kinda, like, warn you. It's like, hey.
Be careful. You're about to commit this to
Git, and then it's gonna be in your
Git history,
which is not a good security,
you know, you know, which is not a
good action to do from the security standpoint.
Yeah. So is that algorithm detecting
any secret string or secrets that you have
in your Infisical
It's anything. It's anything. So it's able to
pattern match. It's able to identify 50 different
secret types, you know, from, you know, like,
different AWS
access tokens to API keys and SendGrid
or
whatever whatever it is.
But, yes, it's able to it's kinda, like,
able to pattern match and identify those secrets
and prevent you from leaking those. So even
if the secrets are not in Infisical yet,
we will catch those.
Okay.
Yeah. And definitely one of the kinda, like,
future directions as well for expansion for Infisical,
you know, working on the in the secret
man the secret scanning realm
because that's something that a lot of engineers
like. You know, you have a single solution
for
that kinda, like, combines these functionalities together.
Alright. Nice.
Let's
kinda change page a little bit to something
we haven't really touched on yet. So we
said at the start that this is all
open source.
There is a cloud product. People can go
and sign up and just let you manage
everything for them.
But as they wanted to self host, that
is an option. Like,
what is involved there, and how does, you
know, how does Infisical keep people from doing
anything silly? What's the encryption technology under the
hood? Is it using cloud KMS? Does it
provide their own keys? Maybe you could shed
a lit a bit more light on that.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So so first of
all, actually, the self hosting so we have
we provide all the self hosting instructions within
our documentation.
And we so, admittedly, we used to have
very, very thorough instructions
because we very recently migrated from MongoDB to
Postgres. And right now, we don't have everything
kinda, like, on par with how it used
to be for Mongo yet.
But, you know, we are we are adding
them over time.
And there are kinda, like, a number of
different architectures that we do recommend
people to self host depending on their use
cases. You know, if, typically,
if if if it's kinda like a solar
project, that's one architecture
that's being recommended. If it's, like, a huge
bank,
then it it's a different one. And we,
for example, have, like, a Kubernetes deployment with
Helm charts available
and, you know, all the steps that people
need to take to to deploy and and
create this highly available environment.
And,
yes, and and and also,
like, we provide different instructions for how to
actually secure your environment.
So how it works is that, you know,
for well, how to secure in your environment,
but also how to secure the data within
Infisical.
And, yeah, you know, we kinda like as
part of our security posture.
The goal of Infisical is to secure the
data
within
Infisical,
but the kinda, like, the
part of securing the environment often physical is
mostly on the team who is self hosting
it.
So we we we can kinda, like, advise
on that, but we can be responsible for
that because it's ultimately
the responsibility of the self hosting team.
And yeah. But but, you know, the setup
is very simple. We actually it's I guess
it's a very interesting story because when we
started out, there used to be kinda like
so many different encryption keys
and
other things that people had to specify when
they were self hosting and physical.
And we actually narrowed it down and made
it kinda like much, much, much simpler.
So a lot of these things are being
generated automatically
now, and you just need to specify a
single encryption key.
And,
yeah, that that's that's how it works. It's
very, very simple.
Nice. I like simple. I like that you
don't have to get six people in six
different countries standing underneath a solar eclipse at
the same time chanting some sort of magic
phrase just to get it to build up.
Very cool. Yeah.
Alright.
So Infisical is simple. It's not simple. It's
open source. It can be simple to install.
The complexity is there if you wanna go
to the documentations. In fact, the sample works
for you, and people can get started right
away. You've already kinda covered on what is
coming up with a few things, but is
there any larger
or longer term initiatives that you're working on
at Infisical that people should be excited about
that you wanna go and share with them
today? Yeah. Honestly, there's just so many things
happening at the same time.
So first of all, for the integrations that
we are that I showed you, something that
we will be releasing soon is bidirectional
integrations.
So,
you you know, sometimes what happens is that
even though Infisical is the main source of
truth for Infisical,
some engineer on the team decides
to, for some reason, to update the secret
in Heroku.
And then what happens is there there becomes
discrepancy.
So with bidirectional integrations, you'll actually be able
to specify, you know, what's the behavior
that you want to follow in case these
discrepancies appear.
And and there is a lot of other
things that we'll be releasing for improving integrations.
You you can kind of think of it
as the integration v two
stage,
and, you know, they're they'll become much more
customizable
if if you want them to be customizable.
But
yeah. So that's another thing. The other thing
that's going to be coming out,
and and that's what we've been working
for, like, quite a long time now is
different authentication methods
for how you can authenticate Infisical
both on the user and on the machine
level.
And, yeah, I mean I mean, there is
lots and lots of stuff around it.
You know, we already support, for example, on
the user level, a lot of different authentication
methods starting from, you know, very simple, like,
email and password
to
SAML SSO to OIDC to LDAP to
all all kinda like it's a lot of
different things.
But there is much more to be added
and also a lot on the machine level.
For for example, Kubernetes authentication is something that
we'll be adding and
so on.
Another functionality,
and and this is gonna be kinda like
another part,
Infisical, and and maybe it would come a
little later.
But, ultimately, it's the secret sharing functionality.
And how we view it is that, you
know, even though you have in physical your
secret management
platform,
sometimes you have these situations where you,
as a developer,
have to send something confidential
to
either another person on your team or maybe
to your clients or whatever it is.
And then you would be able to use
Infisical to basically generate encrypted links
or and and it's kinda like a secret
sharing infrastructure for these sensitive credentials.
Nice.
Wow. Based on all of those things that
you have coming up, I'm assuming nobody in
your team has a minute to sleep because
that is a lot of things that you're
working on. Yeah.
We we borderlines on sleep.
Yeah.
Alright. Well, I hope based on everything that
people have seen and what they've heard is
that they're excited and they're all gonna go
check out in physical at the next available
option.
Any last words for people before we wrap
this up?
No. Thanks so much for inviting me. It
it was it was really, really
fun talking to you and showing Infisical to
everyone in your audience. And, yeah, hopefully,
people are excited. Hopefully, they like what we're
building. And, yeah, if you know, we also
have a Slack channel. You can find it
at Infisical.com//slack.
And feel free to join. You know, if
you have any questions,
just let us know. We reply to those
very quickly. And,
yeah, we'd love to have you try Infisical.
Yeah. And remember, it's open source to go
to GitHub, get involved, and, you know, make
it physical a little bit better every day.
Yeah. We have a huge contributor community.
You know? We we yeah. The open
source is is really at the heart of
Infisical.
And
yeah.
Alright. Well, thank you so much for taking
time out of your morning to join me.
I love Infisical, a product I use pretty
much every day, and thank you for sharing
that with everyone else. And until next time,
we'll see you all soon. Thank you, Vlad.
Thank
you.